the man who passes the sentence should
swing the sword I don't forget what you
are
the rest of the world will not stick
with the pointy mind needs books like a
sword needs a whetstone love comes in at
the eyes the occasional kindness will
spare you all sorts of trouble down the
road don't think someone says before the
word but really counts all desires are
balanced to align with the phone purse
he's only one God and His name is death
lion doesn't concern himself with the
opinions of a sheep when you play the
game of Thrones you win will you die and
only by admitting what we are can we get
what we want
it's always the innocents who suffer I'm
going to die may as well be with a song
in my heart what is honor compared to a
woman's love fatale he's coming for all
of us why cry about it they say the man
goes through life with his battle visor
down you can often be blind to me any
lasers of your size but gods wanted us
to have dignity they wouldn't make us
fart when we died anything with a [ __ ]
is easy to fool but power resides where
men believe it resides there's no cure
for being a condom a good Act does not
wash out the bad nor a bad good a man is
what others say he is are no more it's
better to be cruel than weak no one can
survive in this world without help
the more people you love the weaker you
are treat your oaths recklessly and your
people will do the same people shouldn't
live anywhere you need to burn [ __ ] to
keep warm jugglers and singers require
applause influence grows like a weed
sometime
the severity is the price we pay in the
greatness don't get that you seem you
love it's a rare enough thing a man who
lives up to his reputation it doesn't
matter what we want once we get it then
we want something else you waste time
trying to get people to love you you'll
end up the most popular dead man in town
we do not we wouldn't do our duty now
all men should keep their word Kings
most of all any man who must say I am
the king is no true king is that careful
with that start trying to work out who
deserves what and before long will spend
the rest of your days weeping for each
and every person in the world there's
nothing worse than a late-blooming
philosopher thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it took up my sketch comedy
channel dick soak right here just click
on down right here I'm gonna finish
editing this video
[Music]